[Musica]
l'anno scorso nel 2022 in Italia 2
milioni di persone si sono licenziate si
sono dimesse hanno lasciato il loro
lavoro
Sono principalmente giovani come me
sotto i 35 anni ma una cosa interessante
che forse non sapete è che il 40% di
queste persone non aveva un'alternativa
ci hanno lasciato il lavoro senza averne
un altro dei folli dei folli
e li capisco perché in tempi non
sospetti nel 2018 Io ho fatto la stessa
identica cosa avevo un lavoro fantastico
da manager guadagnavo bene ma non mi
sentivo appagata L'azienda non ascoltava
le mie idee non mi formava non c'era un
percorso di carriera chiaro per me e
questo mi creava veramente frustrazione
perché io volevo innovare l'azienda dove
lavoravo ma non me ne va Non me ne
davano l'opportunità e come me tanti
altri perché le persone non lasciano il
lavoro per lo stipendio questo è proprio
una piccolissima parte una persona su
due lo lascia perché non vede un futuro
in quell'azienda non vede che i propri
valori si rispecchino in quella azienda
e queste aziende la maggior parte delle
aziende dove ha lavorato mi piace
definirle aziende basate su una nonage
culture io vengo da Milano quindi parole
in inglese una dopo l'altra aziende che
basano la loro cultura
sulla conoscenza già presente quindi il
tipo di formazione che viene fatta in
azienda è mirata a trasferire quello che
è già a disposizione dell'azienda il
contenuto nel modo più efficace
possibile Alle persone quindi non c'è
una formazione che faccia crescere le
persone in modo trasversale viene fatta
la formazione obbligatoria della
sicurezza che va benissimo ma oggi non
basta più
dopo che lascio il lavoro faccio questa
follia ne faccio un'altra perché dico no
non voglio un altro lavoro Non voglio
cambiare azienda voglio fondare la mia
startup in questo momento mia madre è
venuta la pelle d'oca dopo che per anni
mi ha trasmesso l'idea del posto fisso
diciamo Tu sei pazza hai incontrato
indeterminato e fondi la tua startup Per
chi non lo sapesse una startup è
un'azienda innovativa che deve crescere
velocemente e ha un modello di business
che deve essere replicabile e scalabile
e c'è una definizione del fondatore di
Linkedin che a me piace molto e secondo
me rende veramente l'idea di quello che
significa fare startup ma secondo me
anche fare impresa
è come lanciarsi da un burrone e pensare
di costruire un aereo mentre si cade
Questo è quello che io provo tutti i
giorni e quando ho costruito la mia
azienda e portato a bordo le prime
persone ho fatto quello che ho imparato
nelle altre aziende io arrivavo la
mattina in ufficio e dicevo le persone
che cosa fare Tu del marketing fai
questo tu delle vendite devi occuparti
di questo e dopo alcuni mesi che per una
startup sono come anni perché il tempo è
veramente denaro in tutti i sensi
stavamo per fallire L'azienda non
cresceva non avevamo clienti non
funzionava Eppure il servizio era un
servizio innovativo
E lì ho capito che avrei dovuto avere
persone molto più brave di me a fare le
cose e avrei dovuto inserire quella che
si chiama la cultura del fallimento
quindi sbagliare farlo velocemente
imparare da quegli errori e ricominciare
perché il contesto dove viviamo oggi e
gli imprenditori in sala lo sanno è
troppo variabile ci sono guerre pandemie
e mercati che crollano la borsa non si
può prevedere quello che accadrà e non
puoi avere una persona che occupa un
ruolo una qualifica professionale ma
devi avere un team che è capace di
riqualificarsi in qualsiasi momento per
affrontare Queste sfide perché nei
momenti di caos solo essere aziende
agili ti aiuta a uscire ed affrontare il
caos in modo soddisfacente quindi dovevo
creare una Learning culture di nuovo
inglese quindi una azienda che non solo
faceva formazione per trasferire le
persone le competenze che servivano per
far sì che facessero meglio il loro
lavoro ma doveva essere un tipo di
formazione che permettesse di abbattere
i muri e farle collaborare in modo da
raggiungere l'obiettivo e la strategia
aziendale quindi dovevo tirare fuori il
meglio da loro e farli lavorare insieme
ed è stato davvero una sfida oggi lo
facciamo e il mio team va da solo
continuando a sbagliare tantissimo ma
sbagliamo impariamo e oggi finalmente
siamo un'azienda che cresce e cresce
velocemente ma come si diventa una
azienda basata sulla formazione e sulla
Learning culture e la fa diventare un
vantaggio competitivo
Ci sono
tantissimi metodi framework si deve
puntare sulla visione sul mindset
migliaia di cose ma oggi vi voglio dare
5 dritte che potete mettere in pratica
già da lunedì martedì quando sarete in
ufficio cose semplicissime
si parte da quando si fanno i colloqui e
bisogna fare le domande giuste Questa è
una delle mie parti preferite Perché
invece di chiedere alle persone che cosa
facevi nell'azienda di prima io guardo
le competenze e chiedo un esempio di
cosa avevano fatto in quella situazione
per esempio quando mi scrivono
capacità di gestire lo stress Ok Fammi
un esempio di quando tu hai gestito uno
stress e com'è andata e li vedi se per
loro lo stress è organizzare un
matrimonio o se perdere un treno e
riesci a tarare un po' il livello
Quando fate i colloqui per la figura di
customer service di servizio clienti i
primi minuti Ciao come va Come stai Che
tempo fa a Belluno a Roma eccetera ho
detto oggi sono andata a pranzo sono
appena andato a pranzo con un nostro
cliente Davide e adesso faccio il
colloquio A te l'ultima l'ultima domanda
al cinquantesimo minuto è stata Come si
chiama la persona con cui sono andata a
pranzo oggi la persona che se lo
ricordato ora lavora per me quindi per
me quella cosa era importante che avesse
avuto l'attenzione al dettaglio
e una che mi piace molto raccontare è
che è sempre verso la fine quando si
sentono a loro agio chiedo che cos'è del
tuo lavoro attuale che non ti piace fare
e la maggior parte delle volte dicono
esattamente la cosa che dovrebbero
venire fare nella mia azienda quindi il
commerciale che mi dice non mi piace
telefonare e no allora forse non va bene
quindi non c'è una domanda una risposta
giusta o sbagliata C'è solo quello che
va bene per l'azienda per quel ruolo e
per quel momento
suggerisco tantissimo di organizzare
workshop sul soft Skills che siano
meccanici persone che lavorano
nell'ufficio che siano persone in
magazzino le soft Skills Oggi sono
fondamentali perché far aiutare qualcuno
a imparare Come comunicare piuttosto che
dare feedback
li aiuterà a essere persone migliori
nella vita ma per formare meglio sul
lavoro io l'ho fatto con il mio team e
anche gli sviluppatori che erano diciamo
persone un po' più introverse facendo un
corso di Public speaking di una mattina
non dovete dedicarci giornate intere
sono un po' usciti dal loro guscio e
oggi le riunioni sono molto molto più
efficaci
far lavorare i gruppi trasversali Questa
mi piace molto perché l'innovazione in
azienda viene sempre ai margini quindi
far parlare il servizio clienti con chi
fa logistica l'amministrazione con chi è
il magazzino far parlare le persone
perché riescono a uscire ottime idee in
quei casi non le ascoltiamo mai non le
mettiamo mai insieme ma avrebbero tanto
da dire e potrebbero portare grandi
benefici in azienda i dipendenti di
Google sono obbligati a tenere un 20%
del loro tempo a progetti che sono
trasversali a quelli del loro lavoro
quotidiano quindi collaborano con altri
team e nascono idee pazzesche e che
funzionano tipo Gmail è nata così
e l'ultima
che è molto semplice ma anche secondo me
è molto potente
di chiedere alle persone che sono in
azienda con voi da anni perché restano
perché quando una persona si dimette se
ne va è già troppo tardi Non c'è modo di
recuperarla è davvero difficilissimo ma
se qualcuno è con voi da 5 10 15 20 anni
perché lì deve avere
visto qualcosa in voi nel prodotto che
lo appassiona e che lo fa restare perciò
prendere mezz'ora del tempo e chiedere a
queste persone perché restate in azienda
cosa Vi piace vi permetterà poi di
attrarre i talenti usando queste leve
e poi a questo punto molto spesso mi
dicono sì ok Alexandra ma
io li formo gli organizzo i workshop gli
faccio lavorare in gruppi trasversali
gli chiedo perché restano faccio tutto
il possibile e questi se poi si
licenziano
pazienza che vadano
che vadano è giusto così perché voi
siete imprenditori con una visione e
dovete avere vicino a voi persone che
riescono a realizzare quella visione
persone che ci credono se le persone
sono lì a passatemi il termine da
scaldare la sedia non ne avete bisogno è
giusto fare pulizia e per tutte quelle
persone che in questi due giorni come
Silvia Marica Giovanni mi hanno detto a
me il lavoro non piace non ci voglio più
stare andate andate e diventate
imprenditori di voi stessi che non
significa aprire una partita IVA
significa
Prendere competenze imparare crescere
diventare la versione migliore di voi
stessi Perché se siete un magazziniere o
un barista o un manager dovete voler
essere il migliore in assoluto in quello
che fate e questo sta in capo a voi
l'azienda vi può aiutare e vi deve dare
la risorse ma siete sempre voi che fate
la differenza e Se l'azienda non ve le
dà andate è giusto così
E se non vi ho ancora convinto vi do un
numero di prospettiva
1,2 milioni di miliardi
questo numero gigantesco è il valore del
capitale umano
competenze e conoscenze delle persone
valgono 2,33 volte di più di qualsiasi
asset fisico dei paesi di magazzini di
logistica di tecnologia di immobili non
c'è niente niente
so se è chiaro niente al mondo che valga
quanto le competenze delle persone
perciò se dovete investire fatelo nelle
vostre persone perché se crescono
persone crescono imprese Grazie
[Applauso]